while it might have seemed like the saw
series was game over when the seventh
installment came out in 2010 there was
still a lot of bloodshed to be had on
the big screen with a little revisionist
history some new and confusing
characters and even more disgusting
traps to behold the eighth installment
of the Saw franchise has an even more
complex relationship to the original
story than the other sequels so let's
walk through how exactly jigsaw fits
into the overall puzzle shall we face
the spoilers or click away now
still dead one of the biggest questions
facing the saw revival was how the
filmmakers would deal with the demise of
the franchise's primary antagonist John
Kramer aka jigsaw unlike Jason Voorhees
or Michael Myers jigsaw never had any
supernatural powers he was just a
wickedly brilliant guy with an axe to
grind and eventually a terminal case of
cancer so imagine the audience is
surprised when John Kramer shows up to
stage a new grisly test series in jigsaw
yes it's the same guy who was laid out
cold and in the buff on the autopsy
table and saw four and he's definitely
alive when we see him in this movie but
he hasn't magically risen from the grave
instead his newest group trap series
actually takes place ten years in the
past even though some clever editing
suggests otherwise and while it looks
like there are five victims to bite the
dust there is one guy who secretly walks
away from the whole thing settling the
score in the beginning of jigsaws group
trap there's one man who's left behind
during the first test because he's not
even awake for it but it turns out that
guy doesn't bite it after all Logan
Nelson who's been analyzing all the new
bodies popping up with jigsaw puzzle
pieces carved out of them seems like a
nice guy throughout the movie until we
learned that he's actually jigsaws
secret protege as it turns out early in
his career he mislabeled John's brain
scans which may have made the difference
in his treatment and prognosis but even
though jigsaw is willing to put him into
the group game for his mistake he
changes his mind and decides he doesn't
want Logan to bleed out over a simple
workplace error and decides to train him
instead whether he's ever worked with
any of the other jigsaw minions remains
to be seen a game of his own the new
bodies that are popping up around town
belonged to victims of Logan's
modern-day copycat game and if each
escaped real punishment for their
various crimes thanks to Detective
Halloran
questionable ethics one of these people
is Edgar Munson who shot by police after
claiming to hold the lives of five
others in his hands with a remote
control
he just so happens to have been the man
who attacked Logan's wife but was let
off easy by Halloran but it's not just
his wife's faith that makes Logan hate
Halloran he also had a girl about his
daughters age pop up on his autopsy
table who was attacked by a guy who
bribed Halloran so he wants to stop the
bad cop in the worst way possible in all
of the people who perished in this new
round of games are dangerous perps who
Halloran has let off the hook recently
eye on the prize as the body count
climbs Halloran starts to suspect
Logan's jigsaw obsessed assistant
Eleanor and for good reason she's been
recreating jigsaws most infamous traps
from dark web scoured blueprints and
seems oddly fascinated by his history
once Logan's old combat buddy detective
hunt catches wind of her sinister little
studio he starts to buy into the theory
that Logan and Eleanor are behind these
fresh homicides
however Logan plants some key evidence
that points at Halloran being
responsible for everything and sets up
for a final grudge match with Halloran
himself a big showdown there are only
three bodies that emerge from Logan's
games which is two fewer than the
casualties of jigsaws original scene
jigsaws final two victims bodies have
never been discovered and are still
tucked away in Jill's farmhouse and
that's exactly where Logan wants to play
in his own final game with Halloran to
make it a total of five players with him
being the sole survivor once again after
planting clues for Elinor to follow in
the morgue she thinks she's leading him
out to the location with Logan knowing
full well that Halloran will follow once
Halloran tries to nab them he's quickly
overtaken by Logan who advises Eleanor
to make a break for it and escape
that's when Logan seizes the chance to
put himself in Halloran in one final
terrible trap the voice over which has
been dubbed from old jigsaw tapes
suggest that it's John Kramer who's
running things and demanding confessions
from the two and it looks like Logan
fails the test and is taken out first
but once Halloran confesses to having
cost innocent people their lives
Logan reawakens full-on jigsaw circa the
first saw style and reveals himself to
be the orchestrator of this trap and
Logan has made a game Halloran cannot
win an alibi Eleanor's part in all of
this is interesting to say the least at
first
she seems to be a perfect distraction
for investigators due to her
extracurricular activity
and then she seems to be a budding love
interest for the widower but in the end
Logan says she's just a pawn meant to
provide him an alibi and support his
story that Halloran tried to kill him
but there may be more to her than meets
the eye
after all Logan seems to be doing this
solely to punish Halloran and now that
he's brought his targets to justice he
has a life to get back to but Eleanor
seems just weird enough to fill the
shoes of a jigsaw emulator
she's obviously good at building traps
and has no family to speak up and even
though she doesn't know she's just
worked with jigsaws latest protégé
she'll probably find out eventually
because Logan can't possibly explain why
Halloran's head ends up looking like an
octopus in the end thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]